there is an old occult book called The  shamsalm Arif or the son of knowledge  this is a book that has an Infamous  reputation as being basically the most  dangerous book in the entire world so in  all of these practices that they  describe which include primarily what is  known as the science of letters  which is the idea that the letters of  the Arabic alphabets have magical occult  Powers the book describes these  practices using these letters and the  various correspondences between letters  the The Mansions of the Moon the  planetary spheres the names of God which  include certain letters and so most of  the book talks about how one can employ  the powers of God not the powers of some  Jinn or demon or something like that but  the powers of God so using quranic  verses or names of God quranic verses  and letters to create talismans to to  protect oneself from actual Danger from  evil demons and so on